[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les acteurs et actrices
hôteliby.com 2 ont un vrai talent pour
la comédie mais pas seulement ils ont
aussi un talent pour la chanson
[Musique]
alors il y a plusieurs éléments qui font
qu'on arrive ou pas à faire ce qui ne
sert strictement à rien toucher son nez
avec sa langue il y a le frein de la
langue déjà en dessous on a un petit
languette là qui empêche la langue de
sortir trop on a aussi la souplesse de
la langue parce qu'il faut qu'elle se
tordent bien pour aller toucher le nez
il y a bien sûr l'anatomie la distance
entre le nez et la langue si vous avez
un nez qui est grand ou long et puis que
vous avez pas beaucoup d'espace là ce
sera plus facile et puis il y a la force
des muscles de la langue alors certains
disent qu'avec un peu d'entraînement on
peut y arriver mais encore une fois
ça ne sert à rien
[Musique]